they don't want to know about Nancy
Pelosi turning down 10 000 soldiers
because he didn't Nancy Pelosi did not
turn down 10 000 soldiers Trump insists
he asked for 10 000 soldiers there is
not a shred of evidence that Donald
Trump made that request for January 6th
she didn't look like the look now if you
had ten thousand soldiers for you know
hundreds of people they wouldn't have
gotten anywhere near the place it would
now consider how funny it is that when
it comes to the turnout in General on
January 6th Trump says there might have
been a million people at his speech at
which he encouraged them to go to the
Capitol but now he says well there were
only a few hundred people at the Capitol
now of course both are lies there were
not a million people at his speech and
there were way more than a few hundred
people there are 700 defendants who
allegedly committed crimes at the
Capitol there were of course thousands
tens of thousands of people but every
number Trump gives is a lie